il est à peine six heures du matin ce
vendredi
et pourtant aleksandar vucic et déjà on
visite officielle et si le président
serbe et si matinale c'est qu'il veut
assister à l'arrivée des premiers mètres
cubes d'hydrocarbures dans cette toute
nouvelle station d'interconnexion
gazière située à une centaine de
kilomètres de belgrade
cette inauguration dès l'aurore c'est
celle du prolongement dans les balkans
du turc stream
ce gazoduc qui permet d'acheminer sous
la mer noire le gaz russe en turquie
puis vers l'europe via la bulgarie et
pour aleksandar vucic c'est 403 km de
pipelines serbes sont une chance pour le
pays
avec ce gaz qui assure la sécurité
énergétique de la serbie pour l'avenir
nous aurons l'occasion d'attirer encore
plus les investisseurs à remote grassois
colloque je tenais à lui d'un lot ce
moment ils vont alors vous avez du gaz
dans toutes les municipalités et
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons du gaz à
valjevo novi pazar dans toutes les
parties est et sud de la serbie de tobin
zahav rania tout cela attire à tous ceux
qui veulent couvrir des usines et nous
avons encore beaucoup de travail devant
nous mais c'est quelque chose qui nous
garantit un avenir plus clair et plus
sur une veste mieux su goodwood
un enthousiasme qui n'a pas trouvé
d'écho outre atlantique
perçu comme un outil d'influencé le turc
stream et son extension européenne font
grincer des dents washington qui n'a pas
hésité en juillet dernier à renforcer
les sanctions à l'encontre des
entreprises associées à la construction
de ce réseau gazier et de son équivalent
en mer baltique
aujourd'hui le département d'état met à
jour la loi casta pour y inclure north
stream 2 et le deuxième tronçon de turcs
stream 2 cette décision entraîne un
risque de sanctions américaines sur les
investissements et autres activités
liées à ces 'pipeline' russe c'est un
avertissement clair aux entreprises qui
aident et soutiennent les projets d'
influence malveillante de la russie que
cela ne sera pas toléré une opposition
américaine révélatrice de l'importance
géopolitique que revêt ce projet turc
stream permet à la russie de livrer son
gaz à l'europe sans passer par l'ukraine
avec qui moscou entretient des relations
compliquées
l'ouverture des vannes du premier
tronçon à ankara par vladimir poutine et
rejeb tayyip erdogan en janvier dernier
a aussi été le symbole d'un
rapprochement passagers entre la turquie
et la russie
la dimension stratégique du turc stream
en vient même à gêner ses propres
bénéficiaires comme la bulgarie qui face
à la grogne de la maison blanche cherche
depuis peu à diversifier ses sources
d'approvisionnement
autant de tension pour un gazoduc qui
n'est pourtant même pas encore terminé
il doit également traversé la hongrie
pour terminer sa course en autriche en
plein coeur de l'europe